with march depending on your place on
earth comes spring weather but no matter
where you are march also is bringing
great games to add to your backlog
because we know you're not done with
horizon or eldon ring yet here are 14 of
the biggest games releasing in march
2022
developed by platinum games the studio
behind near automata astral chain and
the bayonetta series babylon's fall is a
hack and slash rpg with visuals meant to
imitate oil paintings while the combat
is still relatively fast paced the game
looks quite a bit heavier than both
bayonetta and near automata and boasts a
more high fantasy setting also unlike
previous platinum titles babylon's fall
cannot be played offline making it the
game's first live service title
platinumgames has stated the game will
continue to be supported with new game
modes ongoing story content and
additional weapon types at no additional
cost as an added incentive to pick the
game up early square enix has revealed
all players who sign on during the
game's first season will be given the
game's first premium battle pass for
free babylon's fall is currently set to
release march 3rd though those who
pre-order the digital deluxe edition
will be able to start playing as early
as february 28th
can you believe that gran turismo is
turning 25 this year more than 400
different cars will be available in gran
turismo 7 alongside 34 locations and 90
track layouts so you can switch up your
races over and over again while
perfecting your driving skills set in a
car worshiping paradise the campaign
will start you off with a lowly compact
car and you'll be able to race and
upgrade in order to become the ultimate
driver for newcomers you can try out the
series signature license test to earn
driving skills that will come in handy
during full races and with the dual
sense controller's haptic feedback
you'll feel the track as if it were
under you in real life coupled with 3d
audio the game aims to deliver more
realistic positioning for audio sources
so you can tell exactly where the sound
is coming from gran turismo 7 will be
available on march 4th in addition to
the ps5 version detailed here it will
also be a ps4 version
triangle strategy is a final fantasy
tactics style strategy game from square
enix in the game you'll take command of
multiple characters as you work your way
through a complex political narrative
and an ongoing conflict involving three
different forces the game plays out on a
battlefield and the game's art style
takes cues from square enix's popular
octopath traveler triangle strategy is
set to release exclusively for switch on
march 4th
assassin's creed's upcoming expansion is
a 35-hour adventure that makes some
massive changes in addition to the base
games formula putting you in full
control of a norse god in their mythical
abilities controlling odin your journey
into one of the most dangerous areas of
valhalla is meant as end game content
though newer players can receive a
temporary power and equipment boost if
they want to play it early in addition
to finding and hopefully rescuing odin's
son balder you'll also face off against
the unkillable fire god surter
assassin's creed valhalla dawn of
ragnarok releases on march 10th for
everything except for switch
wwe 2k 22 is slated to release on march
11 after taking more than a year off
following the debut of wwe 2k20 which
was filled with bugs and was clearly not
ready for mass consumption one of the
most talked about features for wwe 2k 22
is the return of gm mode which hasn't
appeared in the wwe game since smackdown
vs raw 2008 this mode allows users to
book raw or smackdown and battle the
other show for raiding supremacy
do i even have to explain what gta 5 is
you've definitely played this game
already or stumbled across a bunch of
gameplay by accident the next gen update
for one of the biggest games of all time
launches on march 15th
tunic is an isometric adventure game
with elements familiar to classic legend
of zelda titles meaning you'll come
across an assortment of weapons all with
unique abilities that help you overcome
foes and solve dungeon based puzzles and
as an added bonus the game's foxy
protagonist is just incredibly cute
tunic will release on march 16th for pc
xbox one and xbox series xns
persona 4 arena ultimax is a fighting
game that takes place after the events
of persona 4 golden the game was first
released on september 30th 2014 for
playstation 3 and xbox 360 and is now
making its way onto ps4 switch and pc on
march 17th this release includes all
previously released persona 4 arena
ultimax content such as the original
persona 4 arena story additionally there
is dual audio so players have the option
of picking english voiceovers or a
japanese voice track
final fantasy origin is an action rpg in
the vein of neo featuring a much darker
atmosphere than most previous final
fantasy games the game casts players
into the role of a warrior named jack
who sets off with his allies ash and jed
to defeat chaos jack is able to wield
spells and weapons from an assortment of
classic final fantasy jobs including
dragoon and black mage the game launches
on march 18th for ps4 5 xbox one series
x and s and pc
ghostwire tokyo is at first glance a
spooky japanese take on the premise
established in dishonored which is also
published by podesta softworks but it's
much more than that playing as the ally
of a powerful spectral entity on their
quest for vengeance you make use of
powerful supernatural abilities and seek
to uncover why tokyo's population has
disappeared the city of ghostware tokyo
is altered by the paranormal forces at
play combining traditional architecture
and the urban jungle within underworld
area you'll be using your own
supernatural abilities to investigate
the city along with a selection of
wizard-like combat abilities ghostwire
tokyo is the latest from horror master
shinji makami and is currently only
scheduled to release on two platforms
ps5 and pc this ps5 console exclusivity
was agreed on prior to microsoft
acquiring tango gameworks parent company
xenomax media the game will be eligible
for release on xbox series x and s after
one year
kirby in the forgotten land is a 3d
platformer that takes players to a
mysterious world where they inhale
enemies to steal their abilities players
are trying to save the kidnapped waddle
these and the game also supports co-op
with a second player controlling bandana
waddle dee and we can't forget to
mention the all-new mouthful mode kirby
in the forgotten land will launch
exclusively on switch on march 25th
described as a fully standalone game
this borderland spin-off features co-op
for up to four players and repeatable
end-game content however unlike
borderlands tiny tina's wonderlands
features gameplay closer to something
like dishonored or even skyrim many
weapons will be one-handed opening up
your other hand to wield magical
abilities despite this you'll still have
access to an arsenal of guns wonderlands
will cast you as one of several classes
berserker clawbringer graveborn
spellshot spore warden or stabomancer
who all wield unique abilities
wonderlands also features a multi-class
system that allows for any two of its
classes to be combined which should make
for some interesting class builds tiny
tina's wonderlands is coming to ps4 5
xbox one series x and s and pc on march
25th
if you missed it when it launched in
2020 crusader kings 3 is all about
strategic character-focused gameplay
that unfolds across royal houses during
the middle ages whether you play as a
humble ruler or a cruel king who
oversees a vast empire it'll be up to
you to secure your reign by forging
alliances and making decisions that
might result in an opportunistic noble
plunging of a knife into your back for
its current gen console debut crusader
kings 3 will feature adaptive trigger
feedback on ps5 quick resume
functionality on xbox series x and s and
an all new adapted interface across both
systems that's specifically tailored to
larger screens and console game pads
crusader kings 3 will arrive on
playstation 5 and xbox series xns on
march 29th
after parting ways with metal gear solid
publisher konami hideo kojima relaunched
kojima productions and created death
stranding a game focused on creating
connections literal and figurative this
mostly involves delivering packages as
you climb drive and hike across a
wasteland and work to avoid mysterious
creatures and other dangerous scavengers
the pc version of death stranding
director's cut is dropping on march 30th
so which game are you most excited for
let us know in the comments and stick
with gamespot for all things gaming
[Music]
[Music]
you